the Joe Rogan experience do go on
different shows now as a military
analyst they ask me things and I answer
honestly and I try to do it in a
thoughtful way so example being the was
the CEO of the Roosevelt that was
relieved last couple weeks because he
wrote this letter and you know it was
framed by senior level officials as he
sent out essentially I can open letter
it sounded made it sound like he sent it
out to his entire address book and he
went above the chain of command and so
he was fired it didn't go through the
right proper channels and it smelled
weird to me from the beginning because
you don't get to be in command of a
nuclear-powered aircraft carrier by
being like just some guy right like you
know the military you're in for like 25
years at this point you're a captain and
I would be shocked if he had not got
exhausted every other Avenue to try to
get out what he needed to have done and
he's responsible for fighting that
aircraft carrier he's also responsible
for the men under his command and he and
now we have like 900 cases on that ship
to explain to people the the the ship
was infected yep so they had a couple
cases think they had three to start with
on an aircraft carrier at a docked in
Thailand or something like that you know
maybe in January early February
something like that before really things
got out of control
so you're an aircraft carrier and the
only place worse than a ship in a
circumstance like this was an infectious
disease is probably a submarine but he
saw what was happening and he saw it
starting to spread he saw it as saw that
it was impossible to abide by social
gifts to distancing guidelines and once
you do when you actually have it not
just social distancing but once you have
it how you isolate somebody impossible
to do on a ship and so he saw that and
then the story is that he wrote a letter
a letter and it got picked up by the
Chronicle in Northern California and
that just went out to this huge number
of people so we're not 220 people it was
I've read the letter it's four pages
it's very very well done very thoughtful
it gives two courses of action one of
we're at war and how we can keep
fighting the ship and two if we're not
at war need to take care of these guys
and be ready for when war comes so it's
very clearly
in these four pages very professional
it's on Navy letterhead and it went out
to 20 people and for me I thought you
know what this is very strange
that that he's being attacked like this
from senior level leaders making it seem
like he sent us was entire like gmail
address book now it's still US Navy dot
mil or whatever it's not a secret
it's secret communication but there's
official Navy emails that aren't secret
as well and yeah it bypassed the chain
of command I guess but that at some
point I think is his responsibility he
needs to keep that ship fighting and who
knows what the rehearsal relationship
was between him and the guy above him or
whatever I think there's something
investigation will show it and now then
the the Secretary of the Navy flies from
Washington DC to Guam to give a speech
to these people on the aircraft carrier
and he says that the captain has just
been relieved of duty was either stupid
or incompetent if he thought that what
he wrote in that email wasn't going to
get out to the press meanwhile the
ironic part is that whole thing is
videotaped that whole speech is taped
and there's audio that makes it out to
the media so that's the funny part for
me but then also so then he's fired a
couple days later oh geez and then the
Secretary of the army or the secretary
defense now writes a letter an open
letter that says essentially the same
thing as the captain of the aircraft
carrier wrote a few days earlier got him
fired so it's really interesting I went
on some of these some of these shows and
got to sit down with a couple different
people with military backgrounds and I
was the only one saying that something
doesn't smell right here and this guy
has a responsibility to fight that ship
to support his soldiers our sailors and
something's just not right about this
and now we'll see what happens but but
point being yeah I do get asked about
these things and I answer honestly
because the one of the other guys were
saying on this show was that no train of
command he didn't follow the chain of
command and he should have followed that
chain of command regardless you know the
typical Navy type line but being from
Special Operations and being a
freethinker as we're supposed to do
let's be creative we're supposed to
think you think red sell things from the
enemy's side think about it from that
side of the house and do what we do
which is why we can trouble a lot of the
time in Special Operations because we're
kind of
not military and I mean we're military
but you know we like to like to not
break the rule if we like to bend them
to a certain extent to get what we need
done and that's just very natural for us
but when you're sitting down people
aren't like that and don't think that
way it's kind of interesting but point
being I do get asked about these things
and I don't really measure it against if
I can alienate people or not it's just
hey I would be honest and be open I
would be authentic and that's what
people can trust about me and they can
trust about my writing is that when they
read that they know that I just didn't
get it from somebody else like it's a
part of me somehow and it's very
personal even though it's fiction and
that's what you can trust it if my
protagonist is using a certain weapon or
a certain knife or a sir it's not just
that I googled Navy SEAL knife and
someone's saying and then he pulled that
his Navy SEAL dagger instead like no
that's not how it goes you know exactly
who made it with a relationship all that
sort of thing so when people can trust
is that they're going to get my honest
assessment that's what I owe the guys in
the teams I owe them my honest
assessment that's what I owe the people
above me in the chain of command no
matter what it did I owe them my honest
assessment because that's what they
could trust they didn't have to worry
about whether I'm just telling them
something just because I think that's
what they want to hear or I'm looking to
get ahead because I've never wanted this
to be a career in the military I was
just in there to fight and delete but
that's what they can trust is my honest
assessment and so that's how I deal with
today I'm just gonna answer honestly but
it will be thoughtful it's not going to
be like an off-the-cuff
craziness that I have to go back and
retract or I hope it's not gonna be it's
gonna be thoughtful because that's what
I that's what I owed the guys also was
that thoughtful assessment both up and
down the chain so that's just natural
for me to do and what you're gonna get
today
[Applause]